two of my favorite people usually a
great creative artists and they are
merging fashion and chess Susan Sherman
the chairman of the board and eric
johnson executive director welcome to
the show Thank You Maurice last time we
side here it was only an inception of
conception at its inception the the idea
of bridging chess and fashion and
something a lot of people may not be
comfortable with but you guys have been
working really hard and since then a lot
has happened tell us first of all what
the chest design a challenge fashion
design challenge is so if we said last
time it feels like it was just yesterday
we were here we were pairing six of our
incubator designers with six chess
grandmasters including yourself to come
up with a chess uniform and they've been
working since January on their sketches
which we unveiled at the opening of the
championships you know the other night
and they'll continue to work with the
grandmasters and a really solid
partnership going back and forth until
they unveil their prototypes in August
did a big event here in st. Louis and
then the winner will receive ten
thousand dollars a ten-thousand-dollar
scholarship it's going to be tough I
mean they're working really hard on this
and taking it very seriously I know I
was with mine yesterday audra knows and
we're gonna win yeah I guess we just
cause I was gonna win the rest they can
keep trying that's right how's it been
going Eric at the Fashion phone I was
down there yesterday and I saw you
regalia a bunch of ladies with your wit
I'm laughing it up what I didn't even
know what you were saying but the
laughter was so loud you're distracting
us well every day is an exciting day at
the cinemas Fashion Incubator and we've
been open now since January ninth we
have all of our six designers in place
we're also really working with the
community to bring them into our space
not only to show them what we're doing
but you know offer the fashion designer
community here in st. Louis tools to
help their businesses grow so you know
again I would say that it was a fun
event we had the Women's Club down to
our space to be with our designers and
to understand thank you better and it's
just you know a fabulous way that you
know we're getting
word out about the work that we're doing
so it's what do you see as the net
effect of something like this the bridge
Chesson fashioned together for both
fields well I mean chess what you all
have done here I mean making st. Louis
at chess capital I so the United States
and that your opening they said of the
world has been nothing short of
miraculous and you know we think that in
fashion we can kind of learn from you I
mean you you built this chess campus
we're trying to rebuild a garment
district and you did it in a couple of
years and we're trying to do the same
and I think for us it's really job
creation and economic development so yes
we have these designers and we're
accelerating their businesses but long
term we're looking to bring back
creatives into the garment district and
really start some small batch production
there and kind of bring an industry back
I guess you've brought an industry here
we're trying to bring one back but
you're coming out of New York I know and
now you're in st. Louis what is it like
how exciting is it to be at the
forefront of something like this the
Renaissance once again of fat on here in
st. Louis yeah i mean i think it was
really as i described to say to Susan as
those interviewed for this position is
really a once-in-a-lifetime experience
and you know I think that especially
coming from New York where you know
there's so much going on to come to st.
Louis where we have this rich tradition
in this case of chess and to be able to
merge these worlds and to create
something that together is so much
bigger than any of us could do in our
own is just such a great experience for
our organization and hopefully it's one
for the world chess Hall of Fame as well
well I'm very excited about it like I
said we're going to win Emily quick
answer has a good chance whatever that
style that woman doesn't need a chassis
yeah I got that is the truth that is the
truth but Jen I'm sorry you know we're
competitive and we're looking we got
some interesting design coming I'm sure
they do to what we're keeping our
writers all right can't wait thank you
so much for joining absolutely pleasure
to be a part of this project Susan
Sherman and eric johnson doing their
thing for fashion and chess it'll be an
exciting summer as August comes and we
unveil all these spectacular